this is CL an ocelot she is beautiful  but her beauty is her downfall  twice the size of an average house cat  but with shorter than average legs speed  isn't their specialty they ambush  rodents birds fish if it's meat they'll  eat it we almost lost the Ocelot they're  alluring coat with its distinctive  pattern was highly desired in the fur  trade they were hunted aggressively it  used to be that you could find them  throughout the southwestern US and all  the way down to the bottom of Brazil now  there's only 40 left in the wild in  Texas more exists in pockets of Central  and South America but the danger of  shrinking habitats is always looming  this is the Ocelot  you